[Musique]
mais je vous emmène aujourd'hui faire de
la trottinette dans paris sauf que là on
est à londres donc ce qu'on va faire
c'est que j'ai un rendez vous chez
youtube ce matin à l'ombre on prend
l'eurostar on rentre avec tous les
copains et ensuite on va faire la
tranquillité de leur part y ont
découvert la nouvelle trottinette
électrique de chez omis le modèle
progrès mais juste avant je vais faire
un petit où sa mère faire un petit tour
dans la piaule mercredi la vue de le
taire je suis au 21ème étage d'un hilton
quelque part dans l'ombre
regardez là la vue est complètement
hallucinante pourvoi loi sur londres
c'est vraiment super fête alors regardez
on a fait un petit tour de la piaule
alors là oui c'est très sympathique joli
petit issa papier je vis il ya un petit
coin bureau où j'étais en train de
bosser hier soir pour monter ma vidéo
call coin bureau on va ensuite par là
dans les salles de bain ça le bac est
quand même plutôt pas mal aussi et
baignoire derrière petite baignoire
toilettes compagne donc
ça va devenir votre audience matin à
1h30 du matin à léopold match aller
bosser comme maman alors les petits eux
78 ce matin faire dormir dans le bain
rose n'a quand même pas trop dur ça
c'est dur déjà en plus apparemment part
à 8 heures est pas neuf
ouais mais je pense à 8 heures les bus
ça tombe bien moi je pars à métro moi
[Musique]
bon premier rendez vous de la matinée
parce qu'ici ça se passe chez youtube
culture du goût tranquillement un petit
déj boulot ça se passe plutôt bien je
comprends le retard alors regarde pas
partir alors france avec en avant deux
violeurs
[Musique]
d'ailleurs on est arrivé à paris ce qui
paraît très bien bossé et a bien bossé
certaines vidéos sur en forme un petit
peu nouveau tracé sa voie les voies très
très rapide sur le 1h20 pro s'est
contenté pas content en tout à fait je
suis content voilà de quoi vous vous
voyez tout ça et puis allez voir la
chaîne de bandol
au revoir les copains waouh mois
[Musique]
du coup la main qui jouerait caméra à la
main à la demande des rendez vous rendez
vous nous avons aujourd'hui opéra voilà
opéra à paris
si vous connaissez de cet endroit très
sympathique vous avez juste derrière la
barre à la boutique cher oui on va
cesser c'est justement la nouvelle
trotinette c'est la version
professionnelle qui monte les codes plus
vite qui va plus aux équipes le coup
lors on va danser ensemble
[Musique]
et sur la boutique xiaomi alors je suis
content parce que je côtoie aussi
j'aimerais être content il ya personne
donc bon je suis pas content mais c'est
quand même bien qu'il perçoit pour venir
tourner ici donc ils ont la gentillesse
merci
la nouvelle trottinette électrique
version pro je vais apprendre l'histoire
une balade en sang la tester voir un peu
ce qui se passe on se fait un petit
débrief tranquillement ensemble et puis
après on voit ce que ça dit que vous
allez marque x contraire une jolie
ballade en soit je te la ramène j'ai
plutôt tél il y en a qu'une
en france pointant à venir et c'est tout
mon passé
[Musique]
c'est plutôt pas mal cette petite bête
moi j'en ai déjà une gel a mis les
tricks scooter c'est pas le modèle pro
c'est le modèle de base qui a déjà sorti
un bon petit moment et qui est
franchement hyper bien c'est la règle
des 25 25 km heure vous pouvez faire 25
km vous avez jusqu'à 100 kg du coup pour
faire un peu plus de 25 kilos mais c'est
un truc qui est vachement bien et celle
là elle est toujours [ __ ] à 25 km h
c'est la législation qu'il impose par
contre ce qui est vachement bien si vous
avez un moteur qui est plus puissant
donc lorsque vous allez arriver en cotte
vous n'allez pas sentir de
ralentissement alors qu'avec l'autre
modèle vous êtes sentir tout de suite
aux ralentissements et si la cote est
vraiment entendu comment ça va plus
monter là c'est vraiment hyper
impressionnant ça c'est vraiment le truc
qui m'a le plus bluffé alors il ya
effectivement des différences d'un point
de vue esthétique déjà ce qui est
différent c'est ça la regarde et on s'en
rend pas forcément compte tout de suite
au premier coup d'oeil mais toute la
partie d'aller poser vos pieds un peu
plus large un peu plus longue par
rapport à l'autre modèle en terme de
finition c'est sensiblement la même
chose vous avez freins à disques à la
rien c'est vrai que ça freine un peu
mieux ça c'est un point que j'avais
reproché à la première trottinait je
trouve qu elles freinaient pas
énormément pour ce que vous étiez en
descente qu'il s'agissait de freiner des
fois vaut mieux sauter lâché tout lâcher
à trottinette ça pourrait vous sauver la
vie sur celle là ça va franchement mieux
le freinage est vachement bien
alors c'est pas tous complètement dingue
d'un côté vous et jusqu'à 25 km heure
donc le but n'est pas de faire le fou
fou mais c'est vrai que bon ou point de
vue freinage ça a été améliorée il ya
plus de puissance
il ya un peu plus de place pour poser
vos pieds ça c'est vraiment tout ce qui
est cool
[Musique]
l'autre paquet était aussi améliorer
c'est la partie autonomie alors vous y
25 km avant la pouvait jusqu'à 45 km
c'est quand même quasiment double ça
c'est plutôt cool
d'autant plus qu'avec ces petites bêtes
des fois on a toujours besoin d'aller un
petit peu plus loin et puis forcément
pas de la recharger tous les jours le
moteur est sûr booster joli ça sera un
moteur ou de 300 watts vous aurez trois
modes de conduite
vous allez avoir un mode économie
économie d'énergie dont vous avez avancé
ça n'a pas traîné le plus ça vous
évitera de brûler l'autonomie trop vite
lorsque vous arrivez sur des fins de
parcours normal qu'ils roulent tous cas
de plus normal vous êtes toujours les
bonnes notes dans les pentes ya pas de
soucis et vous avez le mode sport le
mode sport il est cool parce que il par
un peu plus vite vous avez un peu plus
de pêche alors c'est par le truc de fou
non plus on n'a pas faire une formule 1
très costaud vais partir un peu plus
vite ça pète pas mal notre temps qui
coule et que vous aviez pas dans
l'ancien modèle c'est votre petit voyant
et si vous voyez votre vitesse voyez le
mode sans lequel vous êtes vous avez
votre batterie et vous pouvez switcher
de mode mode eco double tap mode normal
le mode d pour le mode démarrage est
double tap
on en mode s c'est le mot sport et c'est
là franchement sa tartine le plus vous
avez comme d'habitude ici à la commande
pour accélérer la commande pour freiner
le petit klaxons tous cas de plus simple
vous avez une protection en coupe
circuit vous avez une protection contre
les surcharges donc si vous monte à 15
dessus ça ne marchera pas de toute façon
à 15,2 si ça ne démarrera pas vous
pouvez la plier il a déplié l'emmener
partout avec vous quand notre allée un
poil plus lourde elle fait 14 ans que je
crois que le modèle précédent fait 12
kilos de bombes anti delta vous faites
un peu plus de sport et puis vous
pourrez la porter partout avec vous est
ce un modèle qui est dispo à 499 euros
tiago intéresse vous pouvez venir
l'essayer à la boutique me store opéra
ou xiaomi store opéra vous pouvez aussi
la pré commander chez eux aussi non si
vous souhaitez la pré commander sur
internet vous a mis un lien en bas dans
la description quintaux
une architecture au bénin lomé ça
m'amènerait à moscou
[Musique]
vous pouvez paramétrer votre anti dette
grâce à l'application xiaomi sommes là
voyez j'ai ma petite trottinette qui a
été paramétré là j'ai mon niveau de
batterie restant alors la vitesse elle
ne roule pas le kilométrage ne roule pas
et l'a ensuite j'ai tous mes paramètres
voyage et le régulateur de vitesse que
je peux venir à enclencher le feu
arrière toujours allumée pour les
questions de sécurité je souhaite forcer
la récupération d'énergie lorsque je
vais freiner tout simplement je peut
paramétrer un mot de passe pour le
véhicule aussi je veux pas qu'on puisse
l'utiliser sans avoir un mot de passe
bon j'ai mise à jour du firmware
affaires restaient sans nouvelle usine
ça on s'en fiche
les infos de base des informations sur
la batterie vitesse et kilométrage
[Musique]
côté sportif les all blacks 10h30
on a donc une trottinette qui va plus
vite qui va plus loin qui écoule à
piloter qui monte les pompes bien pu se
trouve vraiment cool le prix on pourrait
penser qu'il est un peu élevé de 499
euros mais vu ce qu'on peut faire avec
pour moi ça ne pose pas de souci je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez
mark et moi tous en avant comme au tapis
moi je reprends la route parce que je
trouve vraiment cool que another brick
in the wall et l'amélioration des cash
ont décroché le fait qu'on le prenne la
trottinette très sympa et en plus ce qui
est très drôle aujourd'hui c'est que ça
fait un an que je suis au mythe arrive
en france dont beaucoup plutôt pas mal